okay after you have the personal
satisfaction of having won the Nobel
Prize what do you think do you have any
other personal goals well the Nobel
Prize is the big surprise to me I mean
if someone had said in 1984 before we
discovered c60 that I was going to win
the Nobel Prize I thought you know pull
the other one because I I know how good
I am as a scientist I'm oh I'm a good
scientist but I'm not a genius and I'd
known I owe some some of my good friends
are fantastically brilliant scientists
but I'm good good at what I do and have
been very fortunate to have chosen
unknowingly really some very nice topics
and the first thing I was satisfied with
and gave me most satisfaction in sight
in fact more satisfaction than c62
discovery of c60 was making the first
carbon phosphorus double bond we made
the phosphorus phosphorus alkenes and
showed how phosphor alkynes could be
made and we did that to using
spectroscopic technique so a lot of
people are not really familiar with the
number it was my group that was involved
with that together with john nixon and a
colleague at sussex and then the radio
astronomy was really exciting I mean the
most exciting day of my life and
societies was that is when we detected
HC seven and a seven carbon atom
molecule on the radio telescope in
algonquin park in canada and of course
c60 was incredibly exciting after we
knew realize what it might be then of
course it does such a paradigm-shifting
molecule how did that you know the end
of the 20th century we discovered the
third form of carbon a molecule been
around all since time immemorial so that
was very satisfying of course then maybe
it would win the Nobel Prize that was
seemed a possibility and of course it's
it's this very nice to win that award
and that is satisfying to it's a bit odd
because I didn't go into science to win
any prizes it was for me a job and my
main passion to some extent i'm not sure
where I like mother but remember as
interesting for me and it's graphic art
and design so in a sense I would like to
do more of that but the Nobel Prize has
launched you in me into other areas
where spending time I'll sue these
questions and I do a lot of that and I
get questions from people or every day
and from young people which I respond to
from one or two people who and I do
respond to and sometimes get a bit
irritable because they ask make somewhat
silly comments but maybe I shouldn't
answer them but I think if I do have
something I wanted ambition it i would
like to do some more art and graphics
which is an answer to one of the
previous ones and I I do still do these
graphic arts I mean I've just done one
for art and art alley and it's basically
a leon sconce Tallahassee aft and this
in the colors of the of the French flag
and that was very satisfying I get a
great kick out of producing a logo or
design that is good and so this book is
very important to me in the family
because it's a sort of family affair
David's of characters which I've put
into this fund and my wife and other son
involved in in getting the story to work
as an exciting I think exciting one but
also a scientific to give a feel for
scale this little boy gets smaller as
long as long as I I'm thinking of maybe
if that works another book
but I really would like to create
something work of art of some sort
switch and I have done some painting
which I think are not bad and they're on
my Croatoan on info sighs so and I was
going to do that in night when i was in
1985 and then c60 turned up and diverted
me for 25 years away from something i
really wanted to do and would have been
equally satisfying to me as a person